estamos viendo grandes manifestaciones
en Irán y uno de los gestos más
repetidos es el de las mujeres
quitándose el velo en señal de protesta
estamos ante un fenómeno nuevo en el
país o la muerte de amini ha servido
como revulsivo de un movimiento que ya
existía en Irán
en realidad Rodrigo es así las protestas
no son un fenómeno nuevo para la
sociedad iraní recordemos que este mismo
año 2022 los pensionistas de Irán habían
protestado por lo que consideran que son
bajas las pensiones como en 2019 también
hubo virulentas protestas por el alza
del precio de los combustibles que se
saltaron con la muerte de más de 300
manifestas manifestantes sin embargo
Rodrigo creo que es importante señal que
estas protestas por la muerte de maxam
Mini han logrado galvanizar el dolor de
amplias capas de la sociedad civil iraní
y que sobre todo se están librando tanto
en las calles de las principales
ciudades de Irán y también en el
ciberespacio son más manifestaciones que
también están logrando llegar más allá
de la censura de las autoridades iraníes
si la muerte de aminia ha vuelto a poner
en el foco la situación de las mujeres
bajo el régimen de los ayatalá Cómo es
en concreto la situación para ellas
Bueno realmente yo creo que estas
protestas están siendo lideradas por las
jóvenes tanto mujeres como hombres que
están muy cansados demuestran así un
hartazgo por lo que son la rigidez y las
normas sociales de un régimen y que ya
lleva 43 años instalado en el país desde
1979 cuando se llevó a cabo esa
Revolución islámica que realmente
amordaza a las mujeres y que limita
mucho No solo sus movimientos sino su
libertad como ciudadanas Entonces yo
creo que estas protestas están siendo
realmente importantes y de hecho hemos
visto que también en capital es europeas
Como por ejemplo en Madrid se han hecho
eco de estas protestas y se han
celebrado también manifestaciones frente
a la embajada de Irán
si uno de los puntos cálidos de las
protestas es la región del kurdistán en
Irán de donde era oriunda a Mini como es
la situación de los kurdos en el país
bueno recordemos que los kurdos no
tienen un país independiente esto es
proceso producto de los procesos de
descolonización que se llevaron a cabo
en el siglo 20 entrado el siglo XX
cuando se fragmentó y se colapsó el
Imperio otomano y por tanto el kurdistán
No ha nacido como un país soberano
independiente sino que su pueblo tiene
que estar distribuido por distintas
naciones principalmente cuatro como son
Turquía Irak Irán y Siria en Irán hay
aproximadamente Entre 10 y 12 millones
de kurdos iraníes que tienen su propio
idioma son un pueblo con una etnia
diferente son kurdos y hablan el kurdo
Además del persa que es el idioma
oficial de Irán Y si bien son ciudadanos
que están bien integrados en la sociedad
hayan algunos analistas que señalan que
la muerte de y demuestra que quizás hubo
un abuso sobre todo que se violentaron
digamos excesivamente con ella por
pertenecer a la comunidad curva
hemos hablado habla de usted de abusos
de las autoridades en concreto que otros
Perdón que otros abusos se han ido
denunciando Durante los últimos años o
meses por parte de las autoridades
iraníes bueno las autoridades iraníes a
su vez dicen que son alborotadores que
son agentes infiltrados desde el
exterior el propio presidente raíz y
denunciaban el discurso ante las amigas
general de Naciones Unidas ayer en Nueva
York que realmente las potencias
extranjeras tienen medidas de doble
rasero algo que no casa con la versión
que escuchamos de los jóvenes y sobre
todo de la clase media que también se
está haciendo eco de estas protestas y
que Acompaña a esas mujeres que ahora sí
son valientes y se enfrentan a la
policía entonces lo que denuncian sobre
todo Es un régimen tirano que realmente
no permite a los jóvenes crecer en
libertades y y ellos quieren que termine
esta opresión de la revolución islámica
de Irán